en la ciudad de Guatemala existe un
lugar que la municipalidad prefiere
mantener en la sombra se le conoce como
el basurero de la zona 3 de esta montaña
de basura se sustentan unas 40.000
personas ahí entre las 3000 toneladas de
desechos que expulsa la ciudad a diario
los recicladores sacan los materiales
que se pueden vender
flory aprendió el oficio a los 10 años
entonces los tengo que separar este es
cloro que vale menos este es cuadrado
que vale que salga uno lo suyo es el
plástico otros con menos suerte trabajan
con el vidrio exponiendo sus ojos y su
cara o con la chatarra traicionera para
los dedos
es duro pero también nosotros tenemos
necesidad Yo tengo cuatro hijos tengo
que mantenerlos mi esposo se murió hace
tres años yo no puedo dejar de darle de
comer a mis hijos me gustaría hacer una
costurera una que diseña ropa eso me
gustaría hacer
y lo está logrando esas manos que
trabajaron tantos años en manipular
desechos aprendieron a coser gracias a
la organización creamos
para hacer frente a la falta de
oportunidades para los habitantes de la
zona esa ong ofrece a las madres del
basurero clases de costura de serigrafía
o incluso de diseño gráfico tenemos por
acá el resultado final que son estas
bolsas Cindy también trabajaba de
recicladora pero cerró ese capítulo de
su vida para ahora guiar otras futuras
costureras todo con tal de no volver al
basurero donde cada año los derrumbestes
de desechos o los incendios por el gas
metano provocan accidentes mortales
llega también mucha basura que sale del
hospital puede que uno se con
alguna aguja o que pueda que toque
cosas con desechos descompuestos o
papeles de baño en el basurero de la
pocas son las alternativas para soñar
fuera del vertedero